thank you thank you so much I am
absolutely delighted to be back here at
Columbia I want to thank president
Bollinger and Dean jano and everyone at
the School of International and public
affairs it is a special treat to be here
with and on behalf of a great leader of
this city and our country David Dinkins
he has made such an indelible impact on
New York and I had the great privilege
of working with him as first lady and
then of course as a new senator when I
was just starting out as a senator
David's door was always open he and his
wonderful wife Joyce were great friends
and supporters and good sounding boards
about ideas that we wanted to consider
to enhance the quality of life and
opportunities for the people of this
city I was pleased to address the
Dinkins leadership and Public Policy
Forum in my first year as a senator and
I so appreciated then as I have in all
of the years since David's generosity
with his time and most of all his wisdom
so 14 years later I am honored to have
this chance once again to help celebrate
the legacy of one of New York's greatest
public servants I'm pleased too that you
will have the opportunity after my
remarks to hear from such a
distinguished panel to go into more
detail about some of the issues
that we face I also know that Manhattan
borough president Gale Brewer is here
along with other local and community
leaders because surely this is a time
when our collective efforts to devise
approaches to the problems that still
afflict us is more important than ever
indeed it is a time for wisdom for yet
again the family of a young black man is
grieving a life cut short yet again the
streets of an American city are marred
by violence by shattered glass and
shouts of anger and shows a force yet
again a community is reeling its fault
lines laid bare and its bonds of trust
and respect frayed yet again brave
police officers have been attacked in
the line of duty what we have seen in
Baltimore should indeed I think does
tear at our soul from Ferguson to Staten
Island to Baltimore the patterns have
become unmistakable and undeniable
Walter Scott shot in the back in
Charleston South Carolina unarmed
in-depth terrified of spending more time
in jail for child support payments he
couldn't afford Tamir rice shot in a
park in Cleveland Ohio unarmed in just
12 years old Eric garner choked to death
after being stopped for selling
cigarettes on the streets of our city
and now Freddie gray his spine nearly
severed while in police custody
not only as a mother and a grandmother
but as a citizen
a human being my heart breaks for these
young men and their families we have to
come to terms with some hard truths
about race and justice in America there
is
there is something profoundly wrong when
african-american men are still far more
likely to be stopped and searched by
police charged with crimes and sentenced
to longer prison terms than are meted
out to their white counterparts there is
something wrong when a third of all
black men face the prospect of prison
during their lifetimes and an estimated
1.5 million black men are quote missing
from their families and communities
because of incarceration and premature
death there is something wrong when more
than one out of every three young black
men in Baltimore cannot find a job there
is something wrong when trust between
law enforcement and the communities they
serve breaks down as far as it has in
many of our communities we have allowed
our criminal justice system
to get out of balance and these recent
tragedies should galvanize us to come
together as a nation to find our balance
again we should begin by heating the
pleas of Freddie Gray's family for peace
and unity echoing the families of
Michael Brown Trayvon Martin and others
in the past years those who are
instigating further violence in
Baltimore are disrespecting the gray
family and the entire community they are
compounding the tragedy of Freddie
Gray's death and setting back the cause
of justice so the violence has to stop
but more broadly let's remember that
everyone in every community benefits
when there is respect for the law and
when everyone in every community is
respected by the law
that is what we have to work towards in
Baltimore and across our country we must
urgently begin to rebuild the bonds of
trust and respect among Americans
between police and citizens yes but also
across society restoring trust in our
politics our press our markets between
and among neighbors and even people with
whom we disagree politically this is so
fundamental to who we are as a nation
and everything we want to achieve
together it truly is about how we treat
each other and what we value making it
possible for every American to reach his
or her god-given potential regardless of
who you are where you were born or who
you love the inequities that persist in
our justice system undermine this shared
vision of what America can be and should
be
I learned this firsthand as a young
attorney just out of law school at one
of those law schools that will remain
nameless here at Columbia one of my
earliest jobs for the Children's Defense
Fund which David had mentioned I was so
fortunate to work with Marian Wright
Edelman as a young lawyer and then
serving on the board of the Children's
Defense Fund was studying the problem
then of youth teenagers sometimes
preteens incarcerated in adult jails
then as director of the University of
Arkansas School of Law's legal aid
clinic I advocated on behalf of prison
inmates and poor families
I saw repeatedly how our legal system
can be and all too often is stacked
against those
who have the least power who are the
most vulnerable I saw how families could
be and were torn apart by excessive
incarceration
I saw the toll on children growing up in
homes shattered by poverty and prison so
unfortunately I know these are not new
challenges by any means in fact they
have become even more complex and urgent
over time and today they demand fresh
thinking and bold action from all of us
today there seems to be a growing
bipartisan movement for common-sense
reforms in our criminal justice system
senators as disparate on the political
spectrum as Cory Booker and Rand Paul
and dick Durbin and Mike Lee are
reaching across the aisle to find ways
to work together it is rare to see
Democrats and Republicans agree on
anything today but we're beginning to
agree on this we need to restore balance
to our criminal justice system now of
course
it is not enough just to agree and give
speeches about it we actually have to
work together to get the job done we
need to deliver real reforms that can be
felt on our streets in our courthouses
and our jails and prisons in communities
to long-neglected let me touch on two
areas in particular where I believe we
need to push for more progress first we
need smart strategies to fight crime
that help restore trust between law
enforcement and our communities
especially communities of color there's
a lot of good work to build on across
the country there are so many police
officers out there every day inspiring
trust and confidence honorably doing
their duty putting themselves on the
line to save lives there are police
departments already deploying creative
and effective strategies demonstrating
how we can protect the public without
resorting to unnecessary force we need
to learn from those examples build on
what works we can start by making sure
that federal funds for state and local
law enforcement are used to bolster best
practices rather than to buy weapons of
war that have no place on our streets
President Obama's Task Force on policing
gives us a good place to start its
recommendations offer a roadmap for
reform from training to technology
guided by more and better data we should
make sure every Police Department in the
country
has body cameras to record interactions
between officers on patrol and suspects
that will improve transparency and
accountability it will help protect good
people on both sides of the lens for
every tragedy caught on tape there
surely have been many more that remained
invisible not every problem can be or
will be prevented by cameras but this is
a common-sense step we should take the
president has provided the idea of
matching funds to state and local
governments investing in body cameras we
should go even further and make this the
norm everywhere and we should listen to
law enforcement leaders who are calling
for a renewed focus on working with
communities to prevent crime rather than
measuring success just by the number of
arrests or convictions as your senator
from New York I supported a greater
emphasis on community policing along
with putting more officers on the street
to get to know those communities David
Dinkins was an early pioneer of this
policy his leadership helped lay the
foundation for dramatic drops in crime
in the years that followed
and today smart policing in communities
that builds relationships partners and
trust makes more sense than ever and it
shouldn't be limited just to officers on
the beat it's an ethic that should
extend throughout our criminal justice
system to prosecutors and parole
officers to judges and lawmakers we all
share a responsibility to help restate
the fabric of our neighborhoods and
communities we also have to be honest
about the gaps that exist across our
country the inequality that stalks our
streets because you cannot talk about
smart policing and reforming the
criminal justice system if you also
don't talk about what's needed to
provide Economic Opportunity better
educational chances for young people
more support to families so they can do
the best jobs they are capable of doing
to help support their own children today
I saw an article on the front page of
USA Today that really struck me written
by a journalist who lives in Baltimore
and here's what I read three times to
make sure I was reading correctly at a
conference in 2013 at Johns Hopkins
University vice provost Jonathan Bagger
pointed out that only six miles separate
the Baltimore neighborhoods of Roland
Park and Hollins market but there is a
20-year difference in the average life
expectancy we have learned in the last
few years that life expectancy which is
a measure of the quality of life in
communities and countries manifest the
same inequality that we see in so many
other parts of our society
women white women without high school
education are losing life expectancy
black men and black women are seeing
their life expectancy goes down in so
many parts of our country
this may not grab headlines although I
was glad to see it on the front page of
USA Today but it tells us more than I
think we can bear about what we are up
against we need to start understanding
how important it is to care for every
single child as though that child were
our own David and I
started our conversation this morning
talking about our grandchildren now his
are considerably older than mine but it
was not just two longtime friends
catching up with each other
it was so clearly sharing what is most
important to us as it is to families
everywhere in our country so I don't
want the discussion about criminal
justice smart policing to be siloed and
to permit discussions and arguments and
debates about it to only talk about that
the conversation needs to be much
broader because that is a symptom not a
cause of what ails us today
the second area where we need to chart a
new course is how we approach punishment
and prison it's a stark fact that the
United States has less than 5% of the
world's population yet we have almost 25
percent of the world's total prison
population the numbers today are much
higher than they were 30 40 years ago
despite the fact that crime is at
historic lows of the more than two
million Americans incarcerated today a
significant percentage are low-level
offenders people held for violating
parole or minor drug crimes or who are
simply awaiting trial and backlogged
courts keeping them behind bars does
little to reduce crime but it does a lot
to tear apart families and communities
one in every twenty eight children in
our country now has a parent in prison
think about what that means for those
children when we talk about one and a
half million missing african-american
men we're talking about missing
husband's missing father's missing
brothers they're not there to look after
their children or to bring home a page
and the consequences are profound
without the mass incarceration that we
currently practice millions fewer people
would be living in poverty and it's not
just families trying to stay afloat with
one parent behind bars of the 600,000
prisoners who reenter society each year
roughly 60% face long-term unemployment
and for all this taxpayers are paying
about eighty billion dollars a year to
keep so many people in prison the price
of incarcerated a single inmate is often
more than thirty thousand dollars per
year and up to sixty thousand in some
states that's the salary of a teacher or
a police officer one year in a New
Jersey state prison costs forty four
thousand dollars more than the annual
tuition at Princeton if the United
States brought our correctional
expenditures back in line with where
they were several decades ago we'd save
an estimated twenty eight billion
dollars a year and I believe we would
not be less safe you can pay a lot of
police officers and nurses and others
with twenty eight billion dollars to
help us deal with the pipeline issues
it's time to change our approach it's
time to end the era of mass
incarceration we need a true national
debate about how to reduce our prison
population while keeping our communities
safe I don't know all the answers that's
why I'm here to ask all the smart people
at Columbia and in New York to start
thinking this through with me I know we
should work together to pursue
alternative punishments for low-level
offenders they do have to be in some way
registered in the criminal justice
system but we don't want that to be a
fast-track to long term criminal
activity we don't want to
create another incarceration generation
I've been encouraged to see changes I
supported as a senator to reduce the
unjust federal sentencing disparity
between crack and powder cocaine crimes
finally become law and last year the
Sentencing Commission reduced
recommended prison terms for some drug
crimes President Obama and former
attorney General Holder have led the way
with important additional steps and I am
so looking forward to our new attorney
general Loretta Lynch carrying this work
forward
there are other measures that I and so
many have champion to reform arbitrary
mandatory minimum sentences that are
long overdue we also need probation and
drug diversion programs to deal swiftly
with violations while allowing low-level
offenders who stay clean and stay out of
trouble to stay out of prison I've seen
the positive effects of specialized drug
courts and juvenile programs work to the
betterment of individuals and
communities and please please let us put
mental health back on the top of our
national agenda
you and I know that the promise of D
institutionalizing those in mental
health facilities was supposed to be
followed by the creation of
community-based treatment centers well
we got half of that equation but not the
other half our prisons and our jails are
now our mental health institutions I
have to tell you I was somewhat
surprised in both Iowa and New Hampshire
to be asked so many questions about
mental health what are we gonna do with
people who need help for substance abuse
or mental illness what are we gonna do
when the remaining facilities are being
shut down for budget reasons what are we
gonna do when hospitals don't really get
reimbursed for providing the kind of
emergency care that is needed for mental
health patients it's not just a problem
in our cities there's a quiet epidemic
of substance abuse sweeping small town
and rural America as well we have to do
more and finally get serious about
treatment I'll be talking about all of
this in the months to come offering new
solutions to protect and strengthen our
families and communities I know in a
time when we're afflicted by
short-termism we're not looking over the
horizon for the investments that we need
to make in our fellow citizens and our
children so I'm well aware that progress
will not be easy
despite the emerging bipartisan
consensus for certain reforms and that
we will have to overcome deep divisions
and try to begin to replenish
our depleted reservoirs of trust but I
am convinced as the congenital optimist
I must be to live my life that we can
rise to this challenge we can heal our
wounds we can restore balance to our
justice system and respect in our
communities and we can make sure that we
take actions that are going to make a
difference in the lives of those who for
too long have been marginalized and
forgotten let's protect the rights of
all our people let's take on the broader
inequities in our society we can't
separate the unrest we see on our
streets from the cycles of poverty and
despair that hallow out those
neighborhoods despite all the progress
we've made in our country lifting people
up and it has been extraordinary too
many of our fellow citizens are still
left out twenty-five years ago in his
inaugural address as Mayor David Dinkins
warned of leaving too many lost amidst
the wealth and grandeur that surrounds
us today his words and the emotion
behind them ring truer than ever you
don't have to look too far from this
magnificent Hall to find children still
living in poverty or trapped in failing
schools families who work hard but can't
afford the rising prices in their
neighborhoods mothers and fathers who
fear for their son's safety when they go
off to school or just to go buy a pack
of Skittles these challenges are all
woven together and they all must be
tackled together our goal must truly be
inclusive and lasting prosperity that's
measured by how many faiths
get ahead and stay ahead how many
children climb out of poverty and stay
out of prison how many young people can
go to college without breaking the bank
how many new immigrants can start small
businesses how many parents can get good
jobs that allow them to balance the
demands of work and family that's how we
should measure prosperity
with all due respect that is a far
better measurement than the size of the
bonuses handed out in downtown office
buildings now even in the most painful
times like those we are seeing in
Baltimore when parents fear for their
children when smoke fills the skies
above our cities when police officers
are assaulted even then especially then
let's remember the aspirations and
values that unite us all that every
person should have the opportunity to
succeed that no one is disposable that
every life matters so yes
mayor Dinkins this is a time for wisdom
a time for honesty about race and
justice in America and yes a time for
reform David Dinkins is a leader we can
look to we know what he stood for let us
take the challenge and example he
presents and think about what we must do
to make sure that this country we love
this city we live in are both good and
great and please join me in saying a
prayer for the family of Freddie gray
and all the men whose names we know and
those we don't who have lost their lives
unnecessarily and tragically and in
particular today include in that prayer
the people of Baltimore and our beloved
country thank you all very much